[Music]
live
[Music]
this is good day las vegas
now well this morning we are talking
tequila over the past five years tequila
consumption has grown by more than 40
percent it's popular it is very popular
i might be part of that trend so what is
driving the trend here to explain
yazelle from las vegas hot spot moss
poor fever taqueria e tequila we are
celebrating national tequila day on
sunday but we got to get ready we got to
get ready now so that way folks can get
their margarita plans on par so
tell me you know tequila has seen such a
huge growth
what do you think is driving that trend
i think i think just so many new
tequilas
being made is a big thing also and then
just the import has been crazy over the
last decade i think so it's just become
way more popular
i hear a lot of ladies are drinking
tequila on their diet they say it's
lower in calories lower in carbs and so
they've kind of taken it up for that i
don't know if that's true tequila and
soda maybe not in the margarita right
so
sipping or mixed it is everybody doing
it yeah what's the best i say that if
you go to a store maybe you just want to
get a 100 agave tequila anything other
than that i think would be a personal
preference but if you get a 100 agave
tequila you're good you're good so
what's the difference you know people go
okay one's white one's yellow what is
the difference yeah well you have your
silver this one's not going to be aged
at all this you're going to be able to
really taste the flavors of the agave
and then we go into a reposado which is
going to be reposado is
rested which means it's going to be aged
a little bit and then we have it on you
so it just
matters um how they're aged okay okay
you want them young or you want them
older yeah you'll get different flavors
you can have both if you want so what
are we making today we are making a
spicy watermelon margarita this one's
called great balls of fire
okay how do we do it so this is that
moscow favorite yes this is one of your
popular drinks we're going to make a
silver tequila margarita this time
she likes it
okay
so now we're on how many shots this is
just one shot one shot okay we can do
that
so now while you're making this you guys
have some specials coming up on sunday
for national tequila national tequila
day the party starts at 7 p.m we have
buy one get one margaritas we have five
dollar um tequila shots and half off
tacos
well can we have monday off okay i know
we may not be here monday oh i'm just
kidding so what's that you're pouring in
this is agave okay here just to sweeten
it up and then we have fresh lime juice
and
fresh watermelon juice which is big that
we fresh press
and make all of our syrups in home makes
the drinks really fresh okay yummy
i love that and then
what's what's in here is that a taco we
have a um f-bomb yes this is going to be
fritos with a protein of your choice
some cheese
oh it's like a freedom
flavor oh yeah yes okay i love that and
then we have all right go for it heather
oh am i up first what is around the uh
this is gonna be a spicy margarita um
rimmed with tajin
and um
oh that's delicious is that good
that's very good good should you have
enough for a second over there i might
have i might have another one
can i have a taste absolutely yes
all right she's pouring out that's what
it tastes like i like the tahini on the
we'll give you on the edge we'll give
you a little
thank you so much for joining
us having the hour it's never too early
it's five o'clock somewhere after all
right jerry i know it's good i got a
little too much of that on the outside
i'm just gonna enjoy this during the
commercial break here
we'll be right back
stay with us we're sadie
a little spicy
stay with us mercedes says what's
trending after the break